[موسيقى]
يواجه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
اتهامات فيدرالية بزعم
سوء التعامل مع معلومات سرية، لكن
يبدو أن كل ما يريد هو وحلفاؤه
فعله هو التحدث عن هيلاري كلينتون،
ويعتقد معظم الجمهوريين أننا نعيش في بلد
فعلت فيه هيلاري كلينتون أشياء مشابهة جدًا
ولا شيء  حدث لها، كما تعلم،
كانت لدى هيلاري رسائل بريد إلكتروني مع هيلاري
كلينتون، وخرقت القانون
ولم يتم توجيه الاتهام إليها، وقد تم
التحقيق معها بشكل مشهور ولكن لم يتم
اتهامها بالحصول على
معلومات سرية على خادم البريد الإلكتروني الخاص بها،
وأصبحت مقارنة كلينتون
صرخة حاشدة للجمهوريين، لذلك أخذنا  نظرة على
الحقائق
الخارجية،
فلنبدأ بأوجه التشابه،
وجد المحققون الفيدراليون
مشاكل حقيقية في كيفية تعامل كل من ترامب وكلينتون مع
المواد السرية الآن على
جبهة الأمن القومي،
تقول وزارة العدل إن ترامب عرض أسرار الدولة
للخطر،
وخلصت وزارة الخارجية إلى أن
هيلاري كلينتون انتهكت أسرار الدولة.
بروتوكولات الأمان مع خادمها الخاص
وكلاهما ضلل الجمهور الآن
لتوضيح أن سيل ترامب الذي لا ينتهي من
الأكاذيب ونظريات المؤامرة كان
أكثر فظاعة بكثير ولكن تذكر أن
خط الدفاع الرئيسي لهيلاري كلينتون انتهى به الأمر إلى أن
يكون غير صحيح، ولم أرسل أو أستقبل
أي سرية  لا توجد
مواد سرية لا تزال هناك
عدة اختلافات كبيرة بين
القضيتين وهي في الغالب
لصالح كلينتون،
هذا هو نائب مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي السابق
أندرو مكابي الذي أشرف على
تحقيق كلينتون وإليكم ما قاله عن
المقارنة لو حدثت لا
ولكن  ما لم يكن لدينا هو الدليل على
أن هيلاري كلينتون قد
تبادلت أو حجبت عمدا
معلومات سرية، فالقضايا تعود إلى حقائق
وأدلة وليس سياسة،
ولا يمكن أن تكون هاتان الحالتان مختلفتين أكثر من حيث الحقائق،
فضيحة كلينتون كانت تتعلق
برسائل البريد الإلكتروني التي ذكرت معلومات سرية
ولكن  مع ترامب، نتحدث عن
الوثائق السرية الفعلية نفسها
التي احتفظ بها في Mar-A-Lago. ومع كلينتون،
عثر المحققون على 52 سلسلة بريد إلكتروني
تشير في النهاية إلى معلومات سرية. أساء
ترامب التعامل مع الكثير من المواد،
واستعادت السلطات ما لا يقل عن 325
وثيقة سرية من Mar-A-A-Lago.  - لاغو، وعلى
عكس رسائل البريد الإلكتروني لكلينتون،
تم وضع علامة واضحة على العديد من أوراق ترامب على أنها سرية للغاية،
وهناك أيضًا فرق كبير على
جبهة العرقلة عندما تم القبض على هيلاري
ثم قامت بحذف 33000
رسالة بريد إلكتروني مغسولة بمادة حمضية وتحدي أمر استدعاء من الكونجرس
يسمى العرقلة،
لم تكن هناك أي عرقلة على الإطلاق  خطير على
هذا النحو على الرغم من ما قاله ترامب أن
المدعين لم يتهموا هيلاري
كلينتون أبدًا بعرقلة
تحقيقاتهم، ففي الواقع جلست لمدة
ثلاث ساعات ونصف مقابلة مع عملاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
طوعًا، وقال مدير مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي السابق
جيمس كومي إنها قالت
الحقيقة إذا كذبت، فيمكنها ذلك  تم
اتهامهم بارتكاب جريمة في
قضية ترامب، وقد قدم المدعون بالفعل
أدلة دامغة على العرقلة،
ويقولون إنه تآمر لتحدي أمر استدعاء
يطلب منه إعادة جميع
المستندات السرية التي كانت لا تزال في
مار ألاغو، ويقولون أيضًا إنه  أمر أحد
مساعديه بإخفاء المستندات وأنه
ضلل اثنين من محاميه الذين كانوا
يحاولون الامتثال لأمر الاستدعاء
في نهاية اليوم.
كان لدى المحامي الخاص جاك سميث أدلة كافية لهيئة
محلفين كبرى لتوجيه الاتهام إلى دونالد ترامب في 37
تهمة جنائية
ولكن مرة أخرى  في عام 2016، قال كومي إنه لا يوجد
مدع عام معقول كان سيتهم
كلينتون بارتكاب جريمة، ولم يكن هناك ما
يكفي من الأدلة، وقد
خلص المفتش العام لوزارة العدل في وقت لاحق إلى أن
هذا هو القرار الصحيح
للخارجية.